hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
massive changes going on in the world
massive change is going on we're in a
big recession right now
potentially a big bigger than we've seen
certainly in my professional lifetime as
a property investor since 2009
what's going to happen what's going to
happen to property prices
what's going to happen to the market
what's going on with the rules
i think it's going to get tougher as a
property investor are they going to get
are they going to get easier
i mean planning permission we know is
easier we know
it's the truth of it all right i'm going
to give you the truth of it the people
that make up these rules
everyone that makes the rules up in
terms of stamp duty the holidays
furlough i i usually the people
that are making serious money in in what
in property isn't it interesting that
they've locked down
everything right now you can't visit
your mom
you can't attend anything everything's
closed
but they've left open the property
market
they've left it open i'm doing property
stuff right now
i'm one of my properties right now and
i'm viewing properties i'm doing deals
and it's okay
literally you can book a viewing of the
stage and go meet dom
do a deal no problem please pull you
over i'm on the way to your house
so the property market's kept open but
everything else is closed i tell you
what's going to happen
the property investors and the property
developers are just going to keep on
winning
and and i'll tell you something as well
the property market is booming
it's booming booming booming deal
sources i did
we ran a deal selling masterclass
program
a couple weeks ago and guess what there
was tens of thousands of pounds made
at the deal selling masterclass tens of
thousands of pounds why
because people are wanting to buy
properties
and and listen people did you know that
22 percent
22 of people that are buying properties
in prime london in greater london
are overseas investors that don't even
look at the properties
they're buying they're buying blind
they're just dumping money right now
into property
so what's my predictions well i think
the property market is going to continue
to boom for the short time i've always
said i've been saying for
you know right since the very beginning
of this of this um whole pandemic i've
been saying that
2021 i do think there's gonna be a crash
not in every area but in
in in in generally across the property
market i still think that
but guys it's not gonna happen for a
little while stop waiting for the crash
stop saying i'm gonna wait for the crash
to happen stop doing that you know why
because because all of this stuff that's
going on
like the the stamp duty holiday is until
march next year
i mean the the furlough scheme isn't it
interesting that the furlough scheme
you know has just been extended till
march next year they clearly plan
on keeping us locked down for quite a
long time you know i don't think this is
going to
just suddenly go away next month it's
not going to be like oh it's decent it's
december now
oh man don't look beautiful absolutely
awesome
um if you want to see by the way my
castle up there i did a video
um just about maybe a month ago with an
update where i go around this whole
thing
but you know if if they say
furlough is extended until march 21
everything's march 21.
the photo is extending till march 21.
stampede holiday is march 21. what's
going to happen in march 21
well i think what's going to happen is i
think there's going to be a lot more
people made
bankrupt a lot more people are going to
get repossessed there's going gonna be a
lot of desperate people
so my advice is from now until march
okay these next few months is start
really educating yourself preparing and
taking massive action
start getting some good money start
getting some good deals before
it happens i mean it's scary i'm scared
for some people you know it's like
imagine the way that we were told we
were told to have a job
and be safe i mean when i started in
property it was like that's risky
everyone think it was risky what are you
doing
but but but now having a job is more
risky than anything
you know it's my properties that have
saved me through these crazy times
you know so many businesses just gone
bust
you know even richard branson's had
businesses that are going bust but it's
property that saved me so
there's a lot of people dumping their
money into property you say samuel what
should i do exactly though why don't you
just find out how to get discounted
property because they're all motivated
sellers
and then and and then those discounted
properties pass them on to buyers
because there's also a lot of buyers and
charge a fee in the middle
that's the way to start getting income
straight away you know controlling
properties
rent to rents i mean rent to rent
um are still are still very profitable
right now yes tourism is dead so if
you're
appealing to tourists then then no but
if you're appealing to business people
believe me business people are still
operating are business people still
operating guys
yeah of course they are because they are
we're still operating guess where i'm
standing tonight i'm staying in a hotel
are you staying in the hotel tonight
yeah you guys staying in the hotel
tonight
yeah hotel hotels are still people are
still staying in hotels
so you can literally get a property a
struggling little property
and turn it into a hotel how do you turn
into a hotel by sticking it on
booking.com
i mean you know this isn't too
complicated folks it's got to take
action
you know the reason i managed to buy a
castle in my 20s
it didn't happen by just sitting down
doing spreadsheets thinking about what's
what
and planning and how am i taking mad
action and uh
you know so anyway that's my thoughts
i think that it's a very good and
interesting time to be alive right now
because got to get around people that
are winning as well environment is
everything
so those are my monday thoughts
literally filming this right now on
monday
um i'm gonna be posting this at 7 pm
tonight if you enjoy my videos i post
every single day
i've always got something to say just do
me a favor smash the like button
subscribe
tomorrow you're going to be seeing my
boy chris chris [ __ ]
and we're going to be going around some
of his rental rent properties it's going
to be really interesting so subscribe
you'll see that
over and out